Italy is claiming progress in fighting
the coronavirus authorities reported
nearly 3,600 new cases yesterday the
smallest day-to-day increase in almost
three weeks Italy has more than a
hundred 32,000 official cases the third
most of any country the reported death
toll of more than 16,000 seems to be an
underestimate CBS News foreign
correspondent Chris Livesay visited a
town in northern Italy that has paid a
terrible price
good morning throughout this pandemic in
Italy nursing homes have been
particularly hard-hit but perhaps none
more so than here at the Casa de polvo
of nem bro they gave us an exclusive
look inside victim after victim 33 at
this nursing home uneasy magani
a housekeeper who loved walks in the
garden Giulio Bona me a carpenter and
bookworm these are the empty beds that
used to belong to patients who died of
Kovac 19 doctors say but the unnerving
thing is that they weren't tested before
they died so they don't appear in the
official number of code 19 deaths in
Italy the virus struck so hard and so
fast they never made it to a hospital
and it's only those who died in
hospitals that are counted in a national
tally even authorities acknowledge the
actual death toll may be much higher
a tsunami that killed three residents
per day at its peak says dr. bada
medical dolly and could still strike the
52 surviving residents no and neither
have we
she tells me I might have coded to two
co-workers have died and many others are
homesick and it's at home or untold
victims also dime untested and uncounted
like Alice and Roberto Manley police are
quick to collect his oxygen tanks now in
short supply
this disease is wiping out the
generation that built everything around
us says his son during the number of
dead is common even in embro a town
which already has the highest per-capita
death rate in the country we spoke to
the mayor who crunched the numbers
what's the death toll i lord i don't
form to according to our analysis it's
four times higher most deaths simply
aren't counted he says but the families
and friends left behind believe every
life matters and needs to be remembered
it's also important to remember that
under reporting deaths isn't limited to
this town mayor's across the country are
sounding the alarm warning Cova 19 is
even deadlier than we think for CBS this
morning Chris live say nem bro Italy